ما الذي ستجنيه قطر ما الارث الذي يعني
تتوقع ان يتركه همم هذا المونديال لقطر
والمنطقه ايضا
كبير على دوله عربيه دوله صغيره مسلمه
تستضيف هذه البطوله شفنا شراسه الحمله
استمرت مدار على على طوال الفتره طبعا
ممكن تتخذ ان احنا اخذنا المركز الثاني
واحنا قرانا الولايات المتحده لكن هم فاز
ولكن نحن يعني منافسات يعني وصلتني للمركز
الثاني وكان ممكن يقول لنا
انجاز لكن خطا تحب التحدي وتحدث من قبل
وقطر استغلت هذه البطوله مش لانجاح بطوله
وبس استغلت هذه البطوله العمل الجاد
استغلت هذا البطوله للتطوير في البلد همم
اللي يشوف قطر قبل 10 سنين ما راح يعرف
كيف كيف اصبحت
وظفنا هذه البطوله من صالح
المواطن والمقيم على على قطر وايضا بتكون
بطوله استثنائيه وتكون بطوله ايضا تشرف في
العرب